okay we're about to let josh's biggest
fans take over this interview with a
little game we're calling
random fandom
[Music]
what could go wrong everything
let's get started hello grobanites
um we're so glad you're with us today
thank you so much for spending your time
and um this light border is going to
bounce around and we'll see where it
lands and when it does that person will
get to ask josh
one burning question are you ready let's
do that
i feel like the grobanites are going to
unionize after this this is like you've
made them an official thing on the drew
on the drew show
it's almost there it's a very long roll
josh
oh we're still rolling
[Applause]
hello what is your name
my name is melissa vaughan and
i live in la as well i live in redondo
josh can i come up and save your life
yeah come on over i i haven't had coffee
yet so come on
i'll do i'll make i'll make us a cup of
coffee i can bring coffee to you
you're in melissa what is your burning
question for josh
oh my god i could ask you so many
questions but
um aside from
your first grammy performance when did
you really know
you had made it when did i really know i
had made it
um that's a really good question i don't
even think i knew i made it
then i mean i there are times where i
still have to pinch myself and i can't
believe that i'm in a position where i
get to do
what i do um i think probably the first
was when i got to sing
um at the winter olympics uh in salt
lake city all those years ago
and i got to bring my my whole family i
got to my parents and my brother
you know i always say that this business
it moves by so fast when it's in you
and you're just trying to hit every mark
that you can that like when you can
bring people
with you that are family or they can
kind of slow down the time for you and
you can kind of experience it
kind of through their love and pride and
eyes
it just makes it really really special
so a lot of those experiences that i had
when i was by myself were really great
but that was the first big thing where i
got to bring my family and it really
kind of made me feel like okay
all those all those music lessons paid
off oh my gosh
oh no melissa move over i might be thank
you melissa
knight now thank you oh my god we love
you josh we love you so much
i love you right back appreciate it all
right let's roll it again
because it's according to the last one
we're going to be here for a minute
i mean does he have a do you have a joke
any good stories
oh is this the horns the regal horns
we've got someone
regal horns hello how are you what is
your name
how are you my name is cheryl i'm from
new york city
josh we need you to come back new york i
know i miss it now winter is winter is
thawing so i'm gonna i'm gonna try and
get back there
and you were amazing as always thank you
so much that was such a blast thanks for
coming
um my question is um i know you've done
broadway you've done concert on stage uh
numerous times um
what is your most embarrassing moment in
either one of those venues
sure uh i have fallen on my butt a
couple of times
once on broadway i i was in a room like
a kind of a 360 degree show so the
music pit was in the middle of stage and
i played kind of a drunken russian
aristocrat so i had to play drunk most
of the time so
you know i'm dancing around having a
good time and i slipped and i fell onto
the drum set
which kind of actually like very
naturally made like a
ching kind of a sound and um afterwards
you know you got a stage door and you
meet
fans outside and you're signing play
bills and stuff and they're like that
was so
method that was the most amazing thing
that you just do you fall on that drum
set
every night i the key is is to sell it
well because i had to play drunk so and
i was in a padded suit so that helped it
was
and it was a matinee of all things i
mean i had to do another one
you know how do you how do you get
yourself back up after that you know
just confidence wise great question
cheryl
um thank you so much okay next random
fandom
yeah josh there are so many things that
happen on broadway during the course of
a run
and you just try to you try to play it
off now the show must go on
[Music]
yeah who goes there a message from the
king
hello what is your name hello my name's
jackie
from atlantic city oh jackie from
atlantic city
my question is josh i heard you've been
quite the cooking concierge
during this lockdown what's your new
favorite dish to cook
oh um i have cooking i've realized is
something that
um can be a lot more than just
microwaving i this is
a at fort if at 40 years old i had a
microwaving for one cookbook uh and i
realized that cooking is
um is like you know it's it's a lot like
making music you know you got all these
notes now these ingredients you don't
know how they're gonna shape up and
i have been uh trying to support this
last year a lot of really local farms
around here and so i'll kind of go
online and find out where there's really
great produce and stuff and then
what i'll do is i'll just kind of get a
box of all kinds of random vegetables
and then i'll just kind of figure out
how the heck i'm going to cook them
afterwards because there's no better way
to learn how to cook than to just kind
of throw yourself in
and figure it out so a lot of a lot of
squash a lot of
thank you jackie for your thoughtful
question and
i'm not surprised by your answer we
didn't even get into all your
charitable and philanthropic work you're
such a good person josh
that's why you deserve grobanites not
just for your talents
but thank you you're a good dude and
it's important
and i have a quick question which was i
know you were doing a residency at radio
city music hall
and i was wondering are you planning to
pick that up again um
at some point uh i am wait you know so
crazy we had spent so much time working
on this show that was going to go on
kind of indefinitely there and they kind
of gave me the stage to
to just do whatever i wanted and it was
a variety show we did this crazy
valentine's show with with the dr ruth
and bridget everett and
all these people and and it was just a
blast and then of course
we just you know it stopped so we're
gonna we're gonna pick this bucket back
up again
in 2022 now now that we've realized that
there is light around the corner
we're gonna we're gonna go back and do
them because we put too much work into
it it's too much fun the audience had
had a blast so yes we'll be back thank
you well i think new york is waiting and
very excited for that
so hurry back thank you probonites
thank you josh this was so much fun
harmony deluxe is out now
and um josh this was so much fun thank
you hi
drew i love you your crew has been so
incredible i can't wait for you to have
a live audience again and um i just i
love you guys thank you for having me we
love you too
you